la situation au karabagh mais la
communauté internationale dans
l'embarras le conflit en ex jeudi à son
12e jour et ne semble pas baisser en
intensité
l'arménie l'azerbaïdjan multiplié les
bombardements dans la province
séparatiste
une situation qui inquiète l'union
européenne nous avons reçu des rapports
extrêmement inquiétant en faisant état
d'une recrudescence des attaques sur les
zones peuplées qui font des victimes
parmi les civils
nous demandons instamment aux parties de
respecter pleinement leurs obligations
internationales en matière de protection
des populations civiles
cessez le feu également réclamée par le
groupe de minsk
créé en 1992 lors de la première guerre
du haut karabagh un groupe qui compte
comme coprésidents paris moscou ou
encore washington
un consensus se dégage donc au sein de
la communauté internationale pour un
règlement pacifique du conflit
seule exception la turquie fervente
alliée de l'azerbaïdjan est un maître
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan sur un pied
d'égalité revient à récompenser
l'occupant le monde doit soutenir ceux
qui sont dans leur bon droit
nommément l'azerbaïdjan une application
turque dans le conflit qui préoccupe le
chef de la diplomatie française jean
yves le drian
la nouveauté c'est qu'il ya une
implication militaire de la turquie qui
risque d'alimenter
l'internationalisation du conflit
je déplore un nombre important de
victimes civiles pour des avancées
territoriale faible de la part de
l'azerbaïdjan
puisque c'est l'azerbaïdjan qui a initié
le conflit il y aura des réunions demain
genève
d'autres lundi à moscou et nous
formulons le voeu que cela puisse
aboutir à l'ouverture de négociations
des négociations qui reste pour
l'instant à l'état de projet selon le
médiateur de la république autoproclamée
du haut karabagh près de la moitié de la
population de la province a été
déplacées en raison des combats